time and I just want you to get I just
want to get your thoughts on it um
if blessing could kind of cue the video
um because you're talking about SIM PIN
and in my personal point of view
this is simping101
okay let's see
um let's see uh that's good everybody is
your boy oh Shay Duke Jackson
at it again with another episode of the
sir Liberty jump
Brothers
I want to take you back I don't care how
old you are but if you're 50 60 under
you you know what I'm talking about
right
when you're in high school if you're the
average guy you're not getting that much
play I'll Be gonna be real about it
you're not getting that much play
women do not want nothing to do with
your ass
all right then what happens is you get a
little older get a little bit of money
and a lot of times you know in your 20s
a lot of chicks that you wanted to do in
your 20s they ain't got time for you
right but you know what Bobby Blue Bland
the famous singer
had a quote one day he calls it and says
it further on up the Rope further on up
the road what does that actually mean
okay that means that as time progresses
in life things change that's what my
mama you saw my girl may say I always
say age brings about a change all right
now for those of you who don't want to
believe that as my Grandma I said keep
living okay keep on living keep living
now as you keep living you're gonna find
out some black men
a lot of the women who didn't want
anything to really do with you
all of a sudden
you see them in Walmart
you know like I was in Walmart like when
I was back home and I I I'm running into
people oh you know we see you on YouTube
you know we see you doing things you
know he was always a guy I wanted to
talk to all kind of stuff now now I'm
the guy that y'all want to talk to now
right and but now we've never seen it in
real time like we're seeing it with
Angela Simmons and Yo Gotti this is
astonishing right now when Angela
Simmons was in her what would consider
her beauty Prime
and I'm not saying anything's wrong with
her right now because it's not but if we
want to be fair her beauty Prime for
whatever reason Yo Gotti she was not
interested Yo Gotti was doing everything
he could have talked to her in fact
Angela Simmons turned down
uh I believe Master P son Laura was
Romeo Miller and then we know what
happened with Sutton Tennyson God Rest
his soul he passed away because he was
he was killed then even after that she
didn't want nothing to do with him
she wanted to do with him all right he
was still in the inbox he been wanting
her for a long time ain't won't didn't
want nothing to do with him at all she
even got what this boxer dude
uh Daniel Jacobs
even the boxer dude didn't want her no
more all right so the boxer due to her
broke up Angela Simmons had even
contemplated can I date white men
I'm open to dating white men
almost ready to date my ugly ass okay
almost
but now what did we find out
like Grandma said age brings about a
change okay that's what age does it
brings about a change now all of a
sudden we saw Angela Simmons
hanging out with Yo Gotti in Atlanta she
was doing her little stupid dances and
stuff like that and to the song he was
sitting up there looking like an idiot
we saw that
then afterwards what did we see now
we're seeing them hanging out in Dubai
okay now here's what I want to talk
about and here's a danger in some of
this for some of you guys out there
all right this is very important Yo
Gotti represents many of you guys
who for whatever reason
um
in the prime you wanted to get this
chick
she would not deal with you I don't care
if it's Instagram models some of you
guys are working real hard to get IG
models she don't want to deal with you
at all but now here you are you have the
money you've built yourself up you look
different now you're going back to chase
the people that didn't want to do
nothing to do with you I see it all the
time and guess what's going to happen
they're only dealing with you because of
convenience that's what you got to
understand you can't look at it as man I
finally got the girl that I wanted think
about it as why did I get her
she really don't want to be with me
because if she really wanted to be with
me when I first tried to be with her she
would have had time now we can say all
kind of stuff what can we say guys we
can say stuff like this
we can say well you know what sometimes
I'm gonna have boyfriends they're doing
X Y and Z they're doing that they're
doing okay for many many different
things we can come up with all the
excuses in the book as to why she don't
want your ass it's fine with me it's
fine with me we can we can try to
explain it if you if it make you feel
better let's explain it the fact is she
didn't want you then now she wants you
why does she want you I would want to
know that why you want me now
even if you have a chick that you
dealing with her and all of a sudden
start acting funny and then all of a
sudden she want to deal with you again
why you want me all of a sudden right
now
I was missing you
fall for that [ __ ] don't you fall for
that because that's exactly what a lot
of ladies want you to be which is dumb I
want you to believe
that you feel like you so special the
reason why they dealing with you is
because they miss you no it usually is
you're a backup plan you know somebody
needs to make her feel good for the time
being and that's what and that's what
your job is you're there to do that okay
some of y'all I need to understand
natural all right you're gonna be
self-assuring making her feel good about
herself
all right that's it long as you know
that's what it's about it's gonna be
okay but now once you start feeling like
it's gonna be real it's going to be real
as as until whatever you can do for her
because the reality is she might have
hit a wall now I'm gonna play I actually
gonna go there I'm gonna do it straight
women are hitting the wall and finding
what out guys think about it that
they're not what they used to be look at
Amber Rose crying all over social media
she can't get a rich man this is no
different than Angela Simmons Angela
Simmons has found out it's harder now
she don't look bad and summons don't
look bad it's harder though it's harder
when you have more competition in the in
in the amount of guys you can deal with
already are taken that's what makes it
difficult it is difficult it is not easy
so that's why she's dealing with Yo
Gotti number all of a sudden he's short
oh his height don't bother me so much no
more
what's not bothering them so much no
more is that the opportunities are not
there it's not there where are the guys
that's going to be there for these
ladies where are the guys that are going
to spend all that money on these ladies
you're not going to see it they know
that that's why they're going back to
the guys that they did neglected before
and the question is is it going to be
you now I understand it's okay for a
woman to want a man that's going to have
some money and have something I'm all
for that but insofar as you didn't give
me no attention and all of a sudden I'm
gonna be dealing with you now hell no
keep that energy let somebody else take
care of you bye I go deal with somebody
who they want to be with me why I gotta
deal with you I'm not gonna be dealing
with you for what but if you didn't want
to deal with me what I wanted you to do
get your ass
get your ass out of there okay
um right ladies and gents we're talking
about simping
um to to summarize Yo Gotti support you
on your own man okay he is a successful
millionaire rapper and this woman in
2016 Angela uh Simmons he expressed
interest in her she was actually in a
relationship
she had a she had a child for another
man
and
that man died
after he died she went with little Romeo
showing Danny Jacobs and then
she gave Yo Gotti the time in 2022. burn
that yo got his idiot Yo Gotti so but Yo
Gotti waited six years he's an idiot
okay we're gonna get to that he waited
six years we're talking about simping
six years to get the woman of his
quote-unquote dreams I don't think it uh
it falls down to that I think after that
he just as a man his ego Maybe
he thought
you know he still has that chance and
he's tried and tried and he's gotten
there now she get it and I think it's
more about that no I think as a woman
when a man tries too hard you lose
respect for him right you do that woman
does not respect him she's with him for
other reasons she's not with him because
she wants him whatever reason she's with
him that's up to her in it but him as a
man he should know and he should see
that that woman does not respect him
she's already had her little fun she's
went on and had her fun went out with
the guys that she wanted and now she
wants to settle with him well you see
I've got to the point where no one's no
one wants him wants her now right this
this was my point uh yeah go on bro this
is my point earlier women's there's
always a sound would go for the goal
until
they ain't got nothing and then they go
back to the car right right so yeah the
security guys
right yeah so your God is a doorman
right now yeah so remind me
um how old are you I know you're 21
you're sorry
21. so are you I'm 24 24. okay so you're
the oldest one here do you find that to
be common that girls will curve guys in
their early 20s and then give them a
chance later
personally me personally
I feel like if I've gone for a guy that
was initially interested in me
time before another guy is because
another guy has I'm distracted by
something flashy it doesn't necessarily
mean I've settled for you but it's now I
notice you because whatever was flashing
in my face ain't there no more but why
don't you say that the thing that was
flashy was your first choice because
it's kind of like
if something more flashy comes along you
should lose interest in the flashing not
necessarily because say I see something
flashing in the distance and I think I
want that I get closer it's but bottle
cap that was flashing against the light
it could be alert it just looked nice
from first glance from instance now when
I get closer I'll find out more get more
substance I found out okay what
initially attracted me okay that's not
why I mean let me let me ask the guys
though guys you were in six years for
the six years for the woman that you won
he didn't wait I I got six years for the
woman that you want and during those six
years you can see she's got with X Y and
Z man and then you're like yeah
like are you doing that yeah no I'm not
doing that bro I'm not doing that I'm
doing that she's in the public either
there's no way I could do that for me
personally even in the past when I think
of people who have tried to do that
where they want to come back and be like
oh yeah you know I actually like you
it's like wait so you like me when you
went out with him
you know what it's different if it's
golf on road because the guy she was
waiting it's worse now when it's on a
public platform and she probably got
with famous rappers etc etc
it's because they're already public so
people are just going to know nobody
because gossip gossip is possible
for six years and the thing is remember
right and it's a long time
that's not the point he's still trying
to take away in his song in 2006 he
mentioned her in one of his songs in
2016. right saying that he wanted he
wanted her it's 2016. she was with her
man cool that's fine she was with a man
her man died in 2008 died in 2018.
she in 2018 went to Lil Romeo but but
maybe she didn't go to him right yeah
and so off little Romeo then she was
Danny Jacobs and he's still expressing
interest he was the next in line and
then
all of the teddy Jacobs she's like well
I'll give you a chance now and he's like
yes
that's when he became
that is their choice
I can't like even as a woman I would
know a man especially a man if you're
doing that you're a [ __ ] I'm so
sorry
me as a woman I'm not doing that if you
have me once I'm never showing you again
right personal a new FM man does that if
he keeps shouting me and shouting me I'm
just gonna look at you like a beg I'm
not gonna that's exactly as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform term if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible